cathay pacific only recently began
recovering from protests in hong kong
that badly hit demand last year
but the pandemics dealt a second blow
with international borders closed
the hong kong-based airline saw its
passengers dropped by nearly 82 percent
in the first eight months of this year
it's announced it will cut nearly a
quarter of its staff
and shut down its regional unit cafe
dragon
analysts say they're not surprised
unfortunately
it has to be done and now they can focus
on some other areas of restructuring
and making the company more efficient
for the near term because it's going to
take a long time before the market
recovers
cafe pacific is not the only airline in
the region to undergo a major
restructuring last month
singapore airlines announced the largest
retrenchment in its history
cutting more than 20 of its staff thai
airways filed for bankruptcy protection
in may
here in malaysia the national carrier is
in talks to restructure its debts
but the finance minister recently said
the government will not provide any
financial relief or debt guarantees
raising questions about the fate and
future of malaysia airlines
more gloomy days are predicted to lie
ahead the international air transport
association
forecasts passenger traffic will not
recover until
2024 and now a tech startup has begun
testing
a digital solution this is a a sort of a
digital
travel health certificate that a lot
that people are
looking to use to open up borders
instead of using quarantines
so if the industry could get behind
something like that where
governments around the world would
accept that then airlines like cafe
wouldn't be in such
trouble it's called the common pass and
aims to be the first
globally recognized document that a
passenger has tested negative for covet
19 before a flight
the airline industry is hoping this will
help encourage
air travel even if it's only by a small
step
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur